you want to be ordinary you ain't even
got to listen to me when I told you it
will be the best year of your life but
you have to claim it you have to expect
it to be the best year of your life you
have to live your life with the
expectation that great things are coming
your way listen getting successful
whatever you consider successful if it's
Rich whatever it's not a magic trick
rich people don't sleep eight hours a
day that's a third of your life it ain't
for 24 hours in a day you cannot be
sleep eight hours a day you can't live
in L.A and wake up at eight o'clock in
the morning it's 11 o'clock on the East
Coast the stock market been open two
hours they already making decisions
about your life and your ass will sleep
the Bible says he who loves to sleep and
the folding of hands poverty was set
upon you like a thief in the night I'ma
ask you one question I'm gonna go how
many of you in here know somebody who
loves to sleep take yourself out your
comfort zone if you stay in your comfort
zone that's where you will fail let me
show you this we all live inside a
bubble right this is our world we go to
church here we work over here we go get
our coffee over here we go to this park
over here we usually go over here to you
know hang out with friends this is our
favorite Club this is our world this is
our favorite spot on the beach we all
live in this bubble what you got to do
to get the life that God wants you to
have you got to put more air in your
bubble you got to blow your bubble up
expand yourself take yourself out your
comfort zone do not live in your bubble
put some more air in your bubble if you
stay in your comfort zone that's where
you will fail you will fail in your
comfort zone success is not a
comfortable procedure it is a very
uncomfortable thing to attempt so you
got to get comfortable being
uncomfortable if you ever want to be
successful start putting some pressure
on put some pressure on yourself
get out here and get about it look I
love to sugarcoat this thing for you I
love to tell you look you can go out
here and get rich do a couple of things
that happen you gotta get real doggish
you gotta get downright Funk if you want
to make it now like I was telling you
before if you want to be ordinary you
ain't even got to listen to me just go
on about your business if you think
ordinary is cool ain't no problem it's
some really really wonderful Ordinary
People but if you are sitting in this
room and you have extraordinary
aspirations then you're gonna have to do
extra you put extra on top of extra or
ordinary and you come up with an
extraordinary it's no other way I'm
sorry but here's the fact all of you
have extraordinary capabilities all of
you you have to decide if you are
willing to do the things to put you in
that category it's not what makes it
hard is your lack of belief that it can
happen for you the fact of it is though
it's very doable but you got to change
though if you keep doing what you've
been doing you're gonna keep getting
what you've been getting so if you're at
a place in your life and you ain't happy
with it you have to change some things
but you have to make a conscient
interest decision that you're going to
change and it's not dependent on anybody
else it don't matter what your mama
think it don't matter what your
co-workers think it don't matter what
your siblings think it don't matter what
your children think it don't matter they
have nothing to do with it this decision
is yours and yours alone it's two people
born in a hospital every day it's a
person is born in the hospital that's
gonna get a job and somebody born in the
hospital that's gonna give them a job
you get to decide which one you're gonna
be you get to decide if I'm Gonna Be
Rich poor mediocre plentiful happy sad
you you have a decision to make and
that's how it works now let me teach it
to you you walk in the house you pick up
the remote control and you press the
power button what do you expect to
happen you expect the TV to come on
guess what it come on if you want to see
Sports Center Sports Center channel 46
and you press four six and okay or
select what do you expect to come on
your TV sports center and guess what
show up Sports Center they got the
concept of creating a remote from the
Bible the Bible says a man is as he
thinking God created us in His image God
thought of this world he thought of it
so he created it so he made you just
like him that your thoughts can create
things he made you just like it now you
can't go make earth in heaven like he
did but you can make a better world for
yourself listen getting successful
whatever you consider successful if it's
Rich whatever it's not a magic trick
it's not God picks certain people he'll
make rich and certain people he don't he
gives all of us as his children The
Power of Choice you have a say-so in
that you can decide to be rich and with
God's help it's highly doable but you
first have to think it the biggest thing
that always troubled me was my
imagination because it was so big when I
was a kid you know I grew up poor but I
was always imagining stuff you know my
mama once a month would buy a travel
magazine at the grocery store my father
used to be so pissed off Bill why we
spending this money we ain't cause we
were poor she said slick we ain't got no
money to take this boy nowhere but if he
can look in these magazines maybe one
day it'll cause him to want to travel
I've been to so many countries around
the world because of that magazine I
just wanted to go see stuff my mama had
enough sense to plant that seed in me
everything that's in your imagination
God will make it come true for you you
just got to believe that God make dreams
come true you just got to believe man
don't ever give up okay let me let me
show you this that I had to learn Albert
Einstein said that imagination is
everything it's the preview to Life's
Coming Attractions that's what your
imagination is your imagination is
actually very very real everything you
imagine could be a preview to Life's
Coming Attraction everything we have
today came from somebody's imagination
somebody was talking on the phone with
that cord on the wall and got sick of it
and said you know what man if I could
just go outside and talk on the phone we
got cell phones somebody got tired of
driving across the country and said man
if I could fly over there boom we got
airplanes everything you've ever
imagined is real see I tell young people
like this first of all this is how your
imagination work you got to grab this
concept it is impossible for you to
think an impossible thought that is
impossible you can't think something
that ain't possible you ain't that smart
so if it's in your head you gotta ask
yourself how did it get there that's God
showing you a preview of a Coming
Attraction he has for you the problem
with most people is you think your
imagination is Hocus Pocus it's really
not it's a preview overcoming attraction
if you react to your imagination that's
where your real life is it's just God
showing you what he has for you the
difference between successful people and
non-successful people is here I'm no
better than none of y'all I'm not a
better person than you I'm not a better
Christian than you God don't love me
more than you none of that if you want
to be successful you have to change this
this has to change
thank you
[Music]